well I like writing so I usually start
writing a quite an early point mm-hmm so
it's not like I go and do the archives
and stuff but then I come back and start
the writing there's usually a lot of
overlap and I suppose I know I mean what
you find in the archives that you should
or or in documents it done is what
usually it compels you to write with me
it often starts from some vignette or
some story or some really rather
extraordinary episode that you try to
make sense of then you make sense of it
by writing it down setting it to the
frame
but I also like thinking about the
challenges that different kinds of
writing in different kinds of historical
questions pose so it's nice to try
writing different different kinds of
books so one might be a very brief essay
istic impressionistic argument to the
next might be a much more in-depth
down to the ground individual by
individual story so that the writing and
how you how you let the document speak
through the writing and then how you
find some bigger argument out of them